la cour internationale de justice doit
dire ce mercredi si elle s'estime
compétente pour trancher sur une demande
de l'iran visant à annuler les sanctions
nucléaire américaine instauré en 2018
après avoir décrété le retrait des états
unis de l'accord de vienne
donald trump s'était mis à dos téhéran
qui avait tenté en 2018 de traîner
washington devant la cour internationale
de justice la plus haute juridiction des
nations unies la récente investiture du
président démocrate joe biden laissent
cependant entrevoir une amélioration des
rapports entre les deux pays ce lundi
l'iran à travers un appel du pied
diplomatique de son ministre des
affaires étrangères mohammad javad zarif
semble ouvrir la porte à un retour
synchronisé avec les états unis dans les
termes de l'accord de 2015
il peut clairement y avoir un mécanisme
pour soi synchroniser le retour des deux
pays dans les clous de l'accord soit
coordonné ce qui peut être fait le chef
de la diplomatie européenne ue z bord
elle peut mettre sa casquette de
coordinateur de la commission conjointe
de suivi de l'accord 2015 et
chorégraphié les mesures qui doivent
être prises par les états unis et les
mesures qui doivent être prises par
l'iran le président américain a exprimé
son soutien à un retour des états unis
au sein de l'accord mais il a fait
savoir par l'intermédiaire du
porte-parole du département américain
que ce retour ne pourra avoir lieu que
sous certaines conditions
si les arrange remet à respecter
pleinement ses obligations au titre de
l'accord de vienne
les etats unis feront de même et nous
n'utiliserions alors cela comme une
plateforme pour construire un accord
plus long et plus solide qui traite
également d'autres domaines de
préoccupation le porte parole du
département n'exclut pas une
intervention de l'union européenne pour
régler ce litige comme l'a suggéré le
ministre des affaires étrangères iranien
mais il l'a jugée pour l'instant
prématuré
si les relations entre l'iran et les
états unis semblent sur la voie d'une
amélioration
c'est sans compter les déclarations ce
mercredi du président iranien à saint
droit ni aucune clause de l'accord de
vienne ne changera sachez le et personne
ne sera ajouté à cet accord s'ils
veulent de cet accord tout le monde doit
s'y conformer
s'ils ne le font pas ils peuvent aller
vivre leur vie une déclaration qui
montre une volonté de ne pas se
soumettre aux exigences américaines
le bras de fer entre les deux pays
pourraient donc reprend
andres et freiner la levée des sanctions
de washington contre téhéran